let's start with the fact that you're a
programmer
what was the first program you've ever
written or the first one that you
remember
the first memory i have of programming
was probably in middle school and i
remember it was recess
and they had this like this time period
where you could read books and the other
kids were like reading comic books and
stuff and
for some reason i had gotten into decide
yet i wanted to get into computers and i
was playing with computers at home
and so i got this book i think from the
library it was called like how to learn
java in 30 days
so i was
i was reading this book at like you know
the recess
and i didn't understand anything and i
remember i went home and i tried to get
this
thing working and you know if you've
ever written a java program the first
lines are like public static void main
string args or whatever and it's just
like it's so foreign and it's so
difficult to get started and so i was
kind of frustrated i was like i don't
understand anything that's happening in
this book so the first the first thing i
wrote was probably just like a hello
world app in java
but it was so
i felt like i was so confused about what
was actually happening that i later
learned a bit of php and php was like
more fun for me because it was like oh
just print out what you want you know it
didn't have all this complexity around
it so then i got more into php
i started building like some simple
websites i think
learned some html so i think that was my
introduction to programming at least the
very beginning part yeah
you know java has a lot of uh
out of all the hello worlds it can
possibly write java is the one where i
think it's the longest yeah
which is quite interesting because java
is often at least for a long time was
used as the primary programming language
to teach people how to program or at
least about object-oriented programming
i think most universities have now
switched in high school switched to
python
i'm not sure if that's the case probably
better it's easier to learn it lowers
the it makes it less scary it's like
less of a hurdle and certainly none of
them use php i love php and i feel like
it's a dirty secret i have to keep
private to myself like it's somebody i'm
seeing on the side or something like
that because uh it's just not a
respected programming language because i
think there's so many ways you can write
poor code with php yeah which is why
it's not respected yeah it's a scripting
language more so although of course
facebook built like a huge stack on top
of it and valuable company but i still
love ruby to this day ruby is probably
my favorite language python's great too
but i just love
the idea behind ruby that it's like
let's make it easier for the human
harder for the computer and make it a
joy to be expressive and all these
things so
i was never the best computer scientist
but i was a good i was a good hacker i
could rapidly prototype products
and using languages like ruby do a lot
of computer science programs still use
like lisp and scheme and things like
that no no they do for that's like
that's if you're hardcore if you're
legit you're gonna do some of the
functional languages yeah i think
there's a there's a few others that
popped up but
lisp is a distant memory for a lot of
people that's like somebody has did like
you go to library
you dust off the book yeah but uh scheme
a little bit i think if you're starting
i mean there's courses about languages
themselves like programming languages
yeah this might be one of those you know
how there's languages that nobody uses
anymore like ancient languages yeah
you might have to go to school in that
same way for programming languages yeah
back in the day we used to use
parentheses i of course still use emacs
as the editor for most things that i do
and emacs is is um you know a lot of the
customization you can do is in lisp yeah
and that's the language probably when i
first
really fell in love with programming is
lisp because
for
a long time throughout the earlier
history of artificial intelligence list
was the primary language but
it still had a life
in the 90s and the arts where some
people would use it
such a beautiful functional language but
it just somehow didn't pick up
um
that said i should say sort of push back
php i feel like
it's still true that most of the
web runs on php most of the back end is
still is still php
so if you look at you know it's like the
stuff that people don't talk about it's
like what what runs most systems in the
world what runs the most
uh back end what runs most front end
yeah javascript
you know html script i think the stack
exchange surveys show javascript's the
most popular language in the world i
think right oh yeah in terms of
programmers and numbers i wonder
by survey of number of programmers on
stack stack overflow yeah but though
that's also the cutting edge right those
are the people that are just like
excitedly writing code i wonder if
there's
there's people that are just like
maintaining gigantic code bases yeah
i feel like the amount of java out there
just running industrial systems has got
to be enormous and then of course in the
banking industry
finance it's like
even older stuff cobalt and whatnot but
i've been actually looking for somebody
uh to interview
who who represents uh cobalt
unfortunately like who's the figure
still yeah they're still there that
holds the flag i did you know java
founder of java creator of java creator
python creator of c plus plus but nobody
wants to hold the flag for cobalt
unfortunately even though some of the
most important systems in the world
still run on those yeah uh like power
systems and infrastructure systems which
is fascinating which and atms and stuff
like that like a lot of stuff
that we rely on that just works and the
reason we don't change it because it
works well yeah it's written in
languages that people don't use anymore
yeah
that'd be a cool series of interviews
get get the stuff that's like tech that
was invented
40 50 years ago but still is being used
widely i mean emacs is an example of
that
you